before the end of last year
James Gunn said that he'd have
announcements related to the new DCU the
DC Cinematic Universe will be coming out
early in the year specifically in the
month of January
and we waited
I waited I kept keeping a weekend slot
parked for him and he didn't do anything
and I had to slot something else in
every time
last day of the year
and it's not even a press release he
just puts out a video of him rambling at
a camera
that deadline snuck up on you didn't it
James
[Music]
okay so yeah first thing is uh normally
there would have been a Doctor Who video
here it would have been the take two
review for Ascension of the Cybermen
that's getting bumped a week and the
reason for that is I wanted to jump on
this as quickly as I could and also I
need to talk about
um Doctor Who spin-offs because Russell
T Davis has confirmed that those are
being worked on so that'll be Saturday's
video and I wasn't prepared to make that
be a week after Saturday and thought
this into Saturday because then this
would have been late and that would have
been crazy late so
here we are but yes
James Gunn has finally given us some
degree of guidance of what the heck the
plan is for DC projects going forward
and not just films also television which
is worth noting because while the two
had been kept pretty separate uh through
this time with honestly they're being a
fair bit more success in the TV area
than in the movies or at least
consistent success uh in the TV area now
the intention is to have it well to have
it be more like the MCU where everything
is definitively connected uh and
potentially cross over with each other
so there were a few things that went on
in this and you're gonna get my thoughts
on all the very sort of moving parts and
sort of also probably read into uh some
of the bits where he was a little bit
more squirrely with what he said but
we'll get there I do want to sort of
just touch on briefly that he had
previously acknowledged a couple of
things that aren't covered in this video
but there are things that I'm going to
bring up things like stuff related to
the casting so like for instance while
we don't have any new cast announcements
with this
um Gunn himself has said that they are
looking well specifically for a younger
actor to play Superman which boy the
timing of that wasn't great because
Henry Cavill had just had his kind of
return as a as a post-credits scene I
Believe In Black Adam myself and found
the time to watch Black Adam
um so there was that and it was it was
all gearing up like he's back and then
well no he isn't because James Gunn
wanted to go with a
um a younger Superman and actually word
from Dave uh Batista is that they're
looking for younger people you know 30s
and down pretty much across the board
that got brought up because uh somebody
asked Dave Bautista about him playing
Bane because he kind of campaigned to be
able to play Bane and I guess he
actually did talk with James Gunn about
it and James Gunn basically said like
we're we're going younger we're we're
casting in the range of people that we
can expect to be able to still be doing
these parts 10 years from now and Dave
Batiste as great as he is he's in his
50s so and he didn't seem to hold any
hard feelings about that he seemed
excited to see what all happened but it
was just him acknowledging the reality
of the situation so there was stuff like
that we had the recent announcement of
the canceling of Doom Patrol and of
Titans neither of which uh gun is
responsible for those were decisions
that were made before he came on board
that was something that he had to
clarify because obviously the
announcement of cancellation came after
he was in charge and people like forget
that just because you're the one who's
coming doesn't mean that everything that
happens from here on was what you wanted
to happen there's lingering stuff from
the past people who are in charge and
that was also the first stuff that he
brought up because starting he talked
about the four upcoming films that were
basically created for or the old version
of DC films that are still going to come
out
actually hold that thought he did talk
about those but even before that he did
say that he really wants to get
everything universally branded under one
um unified DCU our jobs mine and Peters
is to come in and make sure the DCU is
connected in film television gaming and
animation that the characters are
consistent played by the same actors and
it works within one story and there will
still be some other stuff but he wants
it very clearly branded as elseworld so
that's things that he very specifically
cites specifically uh Todd Phillips
upcoming Joker Sequel and any other
follow-ups from that and Matt Reeves is
the Batman sequel and also presumably
the penguin show that is going to tie
into that are going to be very
distinctly elseworld and we may even say
see rather unique branding to go with
that but he is not talking about the
status of any of that because that's not
what he uh you know had to announce I
don't think he's even really involved in
those it seems to be just a case of him
stepping back like let these things
happen they're successful let them
happen that's not what I was brought in
to try and unify and unify is the big
word this is very much
trying to be the MCU which
I mean I get the DC movies I've always
wanted to be the MCU but also makes me
nervous because it's easy to forget
because of how badly it went off the
rails
the old DC plan under Snyder
also had a five to ten year plan
and announced a lot of stuff that was
coming out now
um Gunn does something slightly smarter
which is that he does not give release
dates even years of release dates on any
of the things past the stuff that's
already been filmed that again predates
him whereas the old DC plan actually had
a whole bunch of dates on it and boy
that yeah that didn't happen so while at
the very least uh he is announcing a lot
of stuff he's not over promising on a
timeline which is good but I still can't
help but be nervous even with him in
charge because to me it seems very clear
that something that's going this big
this quick and this expansive yeah he
might be under creative control but that
feels like a top level executive mandate
because yes he and uh Peter Safran might
be the co-ceos of that division of
Warner Brothers Discovery but they still
answer to people like David zaslav even
even amongst uh
Mega Corporation CEOs I have
almost no respect for David's Aslam at
all but just seeing how big and
expansive this is already makes me
nervous if it's going to happen I would
prefer someone like gunby at the head of
it but I kind of would prefer that they
like
get their feet under themselves with a
couple of really solid core stuff
before they start launching into a whole
bunch of simultaneous stuff that's all
supposed to just come together this is
the problem with planning too much at
the front end it assumes that not only
does your first step succeed but like
your first second third and fourth steps
also succeed because you've already
started work on steps five and six
so if they don't succeed
boy is that a massive ripple effect
that's already what happened with the
previous DC stuff okay but I need to get
off that topic let's talk about what he
actually had to say so uh as I said he
started talking about the four movies
coming out that are not
um really part of his new initiative
there's the upcoming Shazam
um which some people might even read it
as like he's implying there'll be more
Shazam after this he didn't really what
he said was you know Shazam was always
kind of its own thing off to the side
which
um basically feels like he's kind of
going like yeah it gets to be here
because it doesn't really uh interfere
or uh or do anything with the stuff
we're planning forward which maybe
that's leaving the window open to do
more stuff with the property since it's
not overly tied into the old continuity
that they're not really going to be
using anymore so maybe maybe not we'll
see uh next one that he brought up was
the flash now what's interesting about
the flash is he does say that it's a
reset for the for the universe the funny
thing is is that it must have always
been a reset because that movie well
predates his involvement so we have not
heard about any serious reshoots on that
partially because of
all the stuff going on with Ezra Miller
uh probably he would have made reshoots
impractical and I am not getting into
all that again I am I do not want to
talk about them for as long as I can
possibly get away with but it is
interesting that he highlighted the fact
that it's a reset now whether that's to
his benefit or detriment kind of depends
on whether the way the movie ends is by
just making it clear and now the
universe has changed and then it ends
leaving it open-ended for what the new
universe is because that he could just
directly springboard off of
but if it gives a very clear indication
towards the end of what the new universe
will be whatever that is is probably not
going to be the case I so I am going to
be curious to see how that pans out and
how much new
well not reshoots but how much editing
reworking has been done to make it more
the former where maybe initially it
might have been the latter I don't know
we'll see he talks up Blue Beetle a
little bit just sort of saying how you
know it's a cool story and it's a fun
character and doesn't doesn't uh really
say too much more about it I mean that
makes sense that that's a movie that
hasn't even really had its promotional
um cycle begin yet and then he glosses
over Aquaman too
so fast
because
that's actually kind of the one I have
the most questions about right now
because if Blue Beetle is anything like
Shazam then it's going to be fairly
detached from the overall continuity and
can just exist as a standalone thing
before he gets his thing starter and
Flash as I said might even feed directly
into it Aquaman is of the four
remainings come out Aquaman is
definitively a product
of a dead continuity
and he just glosses on past that
if I were to guess I suspect that it
probably is going to be treated as a
final hurray uh for those characters and
that it was probably a condition of gun
taking over that he would not have to
keep carrying that on even though the
Aquaman filmed the wall the first one
definitely probably the second one uh
will also be very successful and
actually I suppose that's worth talking
about real quick there are certainly
some fans out there
um you know fans of the Snyder verse who
aren't happy with how much has just been
swept away Cavill being a big thing and
also just there's no indication that
um gun intends to pick up any of the
possible thing that he could have you
know the films that were already
finished are being allowed to come out
on like what happened the bat girl again
thank you David zaslov but you know
other than that he's not holding to that
old continuity at all
and while I appreciate
the uh frustration and disappointment
that the fans of the Snyder verse
probably have for that especially around
Cavill because they were just getting
excited that he was coming back and then
it didn't happen like that that just
sucks I get that but I don't blame him
at all for going Clean Slate on this
which every indication to me says that's
what this is
because
this is this is where I'm hashtag not
all Snyder fans but this is where the
Snyder verse movement let's go with that
not the fans but the movement restore
the Snyder cotton then later restore the
Snyder verse uh this is where they kind
of made a rod for their own back
which is that they have you know there
was all the push for the Snyder cut and
then they got the Snyder cut
and then they said restore the Snyder
verse
they kind of made it clear that they
weren't going to be happy with just the
thing one thing and it's just gonna put
James Gunn in a better position to wipe
all of it away and yes people will
complain about that and again not
unjustly if you lost something that you
cared about I get that but you know
those people were never going to be
happy with anything you did and if he
kept anything around it wouldn't have
been interpreted as throwing them a bone
they they just they established they
were just going to keep demanding that
it keep going they were going to harass
him to maintain Zack Snyder's continuity
or his ideas or something and the guy's
not going to do that so I think a clean
break was probably
the least painful option both for him
and for fans which again
I get that especially the caval thing
that that hurt for some folks I don't
doubt it but anyway that's me touching
on that and we have now covered the
lingering films from the Snyder verse
what is coming up new
so Gunn calls this whole thing chapter
one well I say this whole thing he says
everything that he talks about is Under
the Umbrella of chapter one but what he
talks about is not everything that will
be part of that presumably this is meant
to be an equivalent of the Marvel phase
one but he doesn't say that but like
it's hard to interpret anything else the
the thing is though that that brings me
back to my earlier point he then goes on
to list like 10 projects I actually I
forget how many it's a lot he lists a
lot of projects
MCU phase one
was
four movies and a team up
it was Fort no it was five five movies
and a team up
they didn't try to enter integrate the
um the TV stuff until later
um they didn't even really have the TV
stuff until later and they didn't really
have any crossover until we got to the
team up so again you're
you're begging the comparison and it
makes me nervous anyways what are we
actually looking at here so he calls the
chapter Gods and Monsters which
initially made me go because there is a
Gods and Monsters animated movie which
is very good but also it's not something
that should be used as a basis for what
this is it seems to be a fairly
arbitrary well not arbitrary but like
the ties to that don't seem to be
relevant it's more about here we are
introducing
all these new Godlike characters and all
these new monsters that seems to kind of
be what he's talking about the very
first thing that he mentions then from
there
is actually really interesting and it's
ambitious we'll see if it's biting off
more than he can chew he talks about
something that he calls the Creature
Commandos which is going to be an
animated series that is in continuity
and he is intending to cast voice Talent
who could also feasibly play these
characters in live action
now that's
it's daring I'll give him that it's the
kind of thing that certainly sounds good
I just wonder
if the logistics are gonna just not be
worth it because Marvel has had various
um incarnations of animated shows as the
MCU has been running including some that
very much spin directly off from the
film stuff but they're not in continuity
like there was a Guardians of the Galaxy
show that is not canon it's not meant to
be in continuity but it came out after
the movie and is building off of those
versions of the characters very clearly
but here gun is is and that's his
kickoff well again we don't know if
that's the first thing that's happening
or just the first thing he wanted to
talk about again he didn't get a
timeline on any of this sneaky little
bugger that he is after that he brings
up Waller so this is Amanda Waller and
he does mention Viola Davis so she is
going to come back now on the one hand
that might seem slightly surprising
because she was cast under the Snyder
regime on the other hand he's already
made use of her not only in his own
Suicide Squad movie but also in The
Peacemaker TV show so he's made it clear
that whether this new universe is
intended to be in continuity with the
old one or not and it isn't he still
intends to make use of her in that part
now he doesn't specifically label
whether this is a show or a movie but he
does cite the people heading it up which
are the uh some of the creators behind
HBO's Watchmen and also Doom Patrol
since that's now wrapped up and since
both of those people come from a TV
background I am presuming that this is a
TV project and there was a mention that
will it will include some Peacemaker
characters though again they are not
currently identified and honestly this
one makes a lot of sense I mean first of
all the behind the scenes talent that He
said they've secured is yeah yeah I'm
I'm yes here for that
um but also just continuing to move
forward with some something connected to
Peacemaker that is also going to be a
show which again he doesn't confirm but
I can't imagine it would be a movie with
those creators involved so that makes a
lot of sense and you have a lot of
potential through Waller to introduce
all kinds of characters you can
initially have her connected with some
Of The Peacemaker characters who are
still around but you know
the very nature of what she does allows
you to introduce
dozens of characters to use later or
just burn off however you feel like
doing it and then there is what will
most likely be the first release Gunn
himself calls this the true start of the
DCU and that will be what is currently
being titled Superman Legacy we know a
little bit about this not from this
video update itself but it has been
confirmed this is going to deal with a
younger Superman I can't recall if it's
been confirmed as an origin story or if
it's just being speculated as one since
they dropped Cavill to go younger but uh
regardless it is going to deal with a
younger Superman and he is intending
this to be kind of the backbone of this
relaunch which makes sense given that a
Superman is the Premier hero of any DC
continuity and he also kicked off the
last attempt at this which is
still in memory so again part of me
wonders if if it might not have been
better to go with somebody else somebody
other than Superman maybe even somebody
other than Superman or Batman as as your
big uh kickoff but
these are the big Power names so it
makes well from a marketing perspective
it certainly makes sense from a let's
really give this a Fresh coat of paint
maybe somebody else would have been
better but this is the world we've got
he is writing this one and I believe
directing it himself so that gives me
more interest in it than I might have
otherwise had in terms of just saying
here's a new Superman story because like
Superman's fine I just you know haven't
loved most of the uh the movies that
have featured him and that's not even
just a DCU thing next up he mentions a
TV show project called lanterns now this
is kind of uh well he kind of Compares
it I think to True Detective this is
meant to be kind of a procedural with
Green Lanterns and that there will be
multiple Green Lanterns in it
um so that is I mean that's certainly a
way to do it it is a it he does say it's
going to be terrestrial largely which it
would have to be because Green Lantern
depending on how Spacey you get with it
can get very expensive very fast and if
it's going to be a TV show they probably
need to control the budget uh a bit and
keep it more grounded uh on Earth it
will be tricky to still elevate it so
that it doesn't feel like
another one of the CW shows you know
flash Arrow
um Legends of tomorrow all that not that
I'm knocking those shows I like some
well I like Legends of tomorrow
but those like looked very much like TV
projects which they were and if this is
all meant to be in continuity
there's probably going to be a little
bit more of a vested interest to have it
all look
Cinema ready and granted something like
Peacemaker did but Peacemaker was also a
pretty small scale story at the end of
the day so it's going to be interesting
to take characters often known for going
off into space to the very center of the
universe and try and tell a smaller
scale story with it it'll be interesting
to see how that balances the next one he
mentions and he does say it's gonna be a
movie is
the authority
and this
oh okay this makes me nervous so the
authority all right there's a couple of
things about the authority a few reasons
this makes me nervous first is the
authority in the comics
can be
very good but the quality of that uh
that book has varied wildly depending on
who writes it Warren Ellis uh created it
initially and had a pretty strong run
then Mark Millar took over and
it was was not good it was not it was
not good at all and the other and so
even beyond having mixed feelings about
the source material uh even knowing that
there is some good stuff there like the
purpose of the authority is to
deconstruct
well superheroes as a whole their whole
thing is that they are what people like
Lex Luthor are afraid Superman would
become someone who uses their power to
go like look nobody can stop us we're
gonna run things the way we think they
should be run because nobody can stop us
from doing it and when you do that well
it can be a really interesting
examination on the corrupting nature of
power and you know doing the wrong thing
for the right reasons or doing the right
thing for the wrong reasons or any
number of things there's plenty uh to
dig into with that
but
in a world where we're already dealing
with series like the boys and invincible
and even like uh The Watchmen series
from a couple years ago this potentially
feels redundant granted that he's saying
this is going to be a movie those were
all shows maybe the shift to medium uh
will help it but then the other thing is
they're gonna have to thread this needle
really carefully to have it not come off
like a dig at the Snyder verse and
kicking them while they're down because
that kind of
at least touching on not necessarily
deconstructing or criticizing but
definitely touching on the notion of
god-like beings that can't be stopped by
normal people was part of Snyder's
approach to characters especially like
Superman now granted Superman's not in
the authority but like
the ideas that they're presenting that
the authority normally presents as a oh
what if this happened like we're kind of
just a little bit what was already
happening or at least already being
explored in what had been the main DC
thing
and again I know that's not the
continuity anymore but like if you do it
wrong it could really feel like you are
kicking the Snyder fans while they're
down and making fun of what Snyder was
not allowed to keep doing
just given the nature of what Stories
the authority tend to be used to tell I
don't know like it could work obviously
it could I know nothing I know nothing
about how they're exactly approaching it
but like
thread that needle carefully man
after that he brings up another TV
project Called Paradise Lost which will
focus on the mascara the home of the
Amazons it is interesting that while he
mentions Wonder Woman it is only to you
to use her to clarify that it's where
she comes from there is no indication
that Wonder Woman would feature in uh
this project and I would say most likely
we probably won't see Gal Gadot back as
Wonder Woman again though I don't think
that's beneficially confirmed one way or
the other but uh regardless this is
presumably set to tell more stories you
know on that island the mythical sort of
end of things which
yeah as long as you don't like do too
many episodes in a season you keep it to
like eight to ten
yeah yeah there's stuff to be told there
get us to know the the world do some
more World building there how much of
the mythological aspects are actually
real how much of it is just mythology
and you know give us give us that sense
like you can you can basically have a
um ancient Greek mythology Style
Adventure show it this could be the uh
new successor to Xena Warrior Princess
if they do it right we'll see again we
don't know too much but oh okay okay I
suppose the other option is it could end
up like that Krypton show which did get
made didn't it that did actually happen
I didn't imagine that right
that did actually
I think it did
I can't remember does anybody remember
did I just slip into the to The
Berenstein Universe I'm supposed to be
in the Berenstain one all right anyways
then there's Brave in the Bold which is
an interesting title to use to introduce
your Batman again separate from the Matt
Reeves and uh uh Robert Pattinson Batman
projects so brave in the Bold right now
is uh still pretty well associated with
a not so long ago very silly and campy
uh animated take which I'm gonna presume
this won't be but that title choice is
interesting and it will be interesting
to see if that's going to be at least a
partial indicator of a lighter tone than
at least the Reeves stuff which would
make sense if only to avoid sort of
brand confusion other than just having a
different actor play Batman have it be
tonally very distinct from the Matt
Reeves would probably be in their best
interest to do he says that he's going
to be basing this largely on Grant
Morrison's run on Batman which
means it's gonna be Damien Wayne
as Robin that is specifically cited so
I'm very mixed on this on the one hand
we have gone so long without Robin it's
kind of ridiculous actually how long
it's been since Robin has been in a
movie other than like vaguely referenced
as being dead already I know Batman and
Robin was a bad movie but that was not
Robin's fault as a concept Robin's a
very core part of who Batman is so I
appreciate that we're getting a robin
again
I just hate Damien
I hate him he's he's such a little turd
I hate him so much now to be fair
to be fair
my most of my experience with him is in
the animated films where that character
appeared so part of my dislike might be
that those scripts were particularly bad
because most of them were and that the
voice actor was uh particularly
insufferable because yeah he was maybe
he's better on the page but also it does
make me worry because
if it's Damian then he can't be the
first Robin
Damian doesn't work as the first Robin
this has to be taking somebody who is a
trained assassin someone trained to kill
and trying to slot him into an
established role of someone who very
much does not do that that's part of the
point but you can't have him be the
first Robin and
James Gunn does mention sort of kicking
off the bat family but he doesn't
mention anybody else so I am going to
assume right now that we are going to
get at least an indication if not the
presence of characters like Nightwing
um or possibly Tim Drake having been
around I don't really need Jason Todd
but again I'm just not a big fan of him
either before or after he died he was
most interesting when he was dead I'm
sorry he was but in any case I'm like
I'm curious about this Batman project
but like I a little nervous next up
Booster Gold as a TV series that's
that's an easy win Booster Gold is a
somewhat comedic character and that's
going to lend itself to an ongoing TV
show quite well could actually very
easily not necessarily tonally but like
in terms of General feel it could very
much just slide in as a replacement for
Doom Patrol so yeah that if you're gonna
do Booster Gold I think doing it doing
him as a TV show makes a lot of sense
next up he cites another movie uh this
one called Supergirl woman of tomorrow
and he says it's got to be based off a
Tom King run on Supergirl now I have not
read Tom King's run on Supergirl what I
am familiar with when it comes to Tom
King's work I'm not impressed like he
must have done some stuff well
I ha I'm not familiar with it he did
some yeah real questionable stuff both
with Batman and with the DC Comics in
general if you've ever heard of Heroes
in crisis well don't mention that phrase
to a hardcore DC Comics fan because they
will either break down sobbing or they
will try to hurt you for reminding them
that that happened so maybe this was a
good run of Tom King's stuff though I I
don't know I honestly don't but
um putting a an emphasis on Supergirl
and also like giving her a movie again
presumably after Superman's could give a
really interesting contrast of the
different ways and methodology of being
Heroes and not just between people with
completely different Power sets or
people who don't even have powers like
contrasting Batman with Superman but
actually contrasting two people with a
similar ideological Outlook and the same
power set
but also doing something different
there's potential there you do it wrong
it just becomes redundant and it's like
why do we need girl Superman we already
have Superman so I'm I would hope gun
would know enough to know that it's got
to be something different from that so
it doesn't feel that way but again we'll
see and again that was confirmed for a
movie last thing he mentions is Swamp
Thing which of course did have a series
it only got one season so that was
canceled
ages ago
um and he does not clarify whether this
one's a movie or a show I do imagine
though the folks over at DC probably
kicking themselves a bit when they saw
that man thing showed up in the werewolf
By Night Special that Marvel did uh over
on Disney plus but uh he does mention
Swamp Thing being a more uh very
different totaling being more horror
driven which Swamp Thing should be to be
completely honest and
that is another thing that I'm like it
sort of lends the the notion of things
like this is ambitious
hopefully not too ambitious because it's
an ambitious thing to go tonally dark
and have it be in continuity with stuff
that is presumably meant to be lighter
than the last guy's stuff
but
um
on its own I'm like okay sure but that
with the uh potential ambition of trying
to have a Batman that is entertaining
yet distinct enough from the ongoing
Matt Reeves stuff to also have an
animated show that is going to be in
continuity possibly with the same actors
voicing as may appear in other stuff
like the the there's a lot of stuff
there's a lot of ambition in these plans
and this isn't the complete plan that's
the other thing and this is supposedly
chapter one if I take any individual
project on its own I can go yeah
yeah I could see that working
hearing about all of them at once at the
same time when we don't
really know how this is all going to go
down like the closest we have to a
kickoff for this is I guess
uh Gun Zone Suicide Squad and Peacemaker
which
uh may not be super indicative given
that those are intended to be R-rated
and a lot of the projects that I
mentioned probably aren't
each individual thing I'm like
cool potential
hearing about them all at once just
makes me nervous
I'm I'm nervous just because
and I know he's not personally writing
and directing all this stuff I know that
but he is writing and directing some of
it at the same time he's trying to
orchestrate all this
and that is something that makes me a
little nervous like I appreciate James
Gunn he's an incredibly talented guy
but Kevin feige over Marvel doesn't also
Direct
I mean granted he I'm not sure he could
and I don't think he has Ambitions to
but like
I think if he even wanted to try it
would be a bad idea
you got enough on your plate
and I'm a little bit nervous that this
is going to be
possibly the Folly that it's he's just
taking on too much if nothing else even
if it's good I'm worried about him
burning out
but
hopefully he knows his work capacity and
and what he can manage better than I do
there's a lot to get excited for and
obviously right now it's very abstract
right now it's all ideas
uh until we get things like casting
costume reveals first trailers find out
more about uh especially with some of
the movie projects who's directing who's
writing them because we don't know a lot
of this for a lot of it there's only a
handful of these that we know the talent
attached and the times where we do know
it's like oh okay like James Gunn
working on the um the Superman Project
the some of the creators behind Doom
Patrol and some of the ones behind
Watchmen working on uh the Waller thing
like okay so like where I'm hearing the
talent I'm hearing good talent
I I I'll relax a little bit when we get
more names attached I think is where I'm
at right now because right now this is a
very ambitious plan
that with the right people
could work but boy that's
that is a that is a tricky and pretty
Narrow Path you're trying to walk and
it's going to be very easy to fall off
it
but we'll see I'm gonna remain as
hopeful as I can given the nature of my
brain to sort of see just I can't stop
my brain from picking apart the ways in
which something might go wrong it's just
a thing that I do I can't I literally
can't stop myself from doing it I've
I've tried I can't but even taking that
into account yeah there's some reasons
to have early hope like don't go crazy
yet we don't I don't think we have
enough information to get properly hyped
but
yeah I want to hear more
and maybe have a more uh intricate
presentation than the oh crap it's the
last day of the month that I told them
I'd give them something quick sit me
down in front of a camera kind of
presentation next time maybe
yeah
whatever
so all these plans for DC Movies TV etc
etc what do you think about them
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't do that the like share
subscribe help me out
but don't worry too much about it
because what I want you to remember is
that you are beautiful you are valid and
you are loved you are the council I'm
just running the meeting and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
oh it's patreon supporter Shout Out Time
folks so thank you to Robin Moore Zubin
look fulla Tarak the thing that goes
doink in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters IMU delki Theo
the Boyd toy lowly Becky Sparkman for
Nabi lacks the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
General contact unit Problem Child angry
gaspro Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose thanks so
much for your help you can get your name
right out too check out the rewards in
the patreon
what they should do should be checked
[Music]